welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Hayden Christensen Anakin
Skywalker has returned to Star Wars in
Ahsoka his ghostly DH form appearing in
the world Between Worlds everyone is now
wondering if this is really Anakin
Skywalker or some kind of cosmic
imposter and after some initial
speculation in my episode breakdown I
decided to do my thing where I literally
re-watched everything again twice and
you know what I found some pretty big
clues why did I do this well because I
really don't want to go to the Baroque
route and overthink this and just leave
you with some loose guess based on an
assumption that Dave filoni is making
the show only for people who have seen
every episode of rebels and Clone Wars I
really want all of us to eat the most
out of the show to come from an informed
place to avoid the typical fan
disappointment when we're LED astray by
these theories and properly
understand Dave baloney's intentions of
the world Between Worlds what it can do
and more importantly what it cannot do
so in short it helps to know who the son
is but there might be more interesting
things for Anakin to be to Ahsoka and
the question we should be asking is not
is this Anakin it's how did Ahsoka get
here now I did break down the rebel
season 4 World Between Worlds episode in
the finale of our four-part Rebels
re-watch series and the best thing you
can do to catch up on everything you
need to know from Rebels is just watch
those four videos okay so the world
Between Worlds is a cosmic dimension in
which all points in time and space are
connected by the force it was introduced
in Rebels season 4 episode 13 a world
Between Worlds Ezra Bridger activates a
mural of the Gods of mortis and enters
This Plane where he hears voices from
the future in the past he saves thehsoka
from her duel with Vader back from the
season 2 finale we had never seen how
Ahsoka survived that duel and Ezra pulls
her away from Vader's killing blow to be
clear Ezra did not change history in
this moment in the Final Shots of that
season 2 episode Ahsoka walked away from
that battle so now Ezra really just
closed the loop of the history that was
always set in course that way but Ezra
initially misunderstands this he thinks
he can alter history to save Kane and
Jairus but Ahsoka explains that Kanan
diets that others could live so the
episode ends with Ezra and Ahsoka
leaving the world Between Worlds and
Ezra really closes this gate by
connecting with the sun part of the
mirror girl to destroy the temple now to
quickly address the theory I posed in my
episode breakdown on Wednesday is Anakin
here in the world Between Worlds
disguise used by the god known as the
sun given the dark tones with the Vader
music we hear at the end of the episode
the fact that Ahsoka met the bird more
eye the first time she went in the world
Between Worlds and more eyes a
representation of the daughter yeah the
theory is a fun thing to think about the
gods of mortis are how Ezra accessed the
world Between Worlds to begin with and
ahsoka's connection to the daughter is
important and Anakin's connection to the
sun foreshadowed his fall to the dark
side but I want us all to just you know
hypothetically game this out if felony
were to introduce live-action Gods to
Star Wars and bring back Hayden
Christensen just to melt the actor away
into a pale deity many viewers don't
recognize even if that deity were to be
played by someone like Sam whitwer yeah
that would blow our minds but feloni's
goal with the world Between Worlds was
to ground that surreal imagery with as
much classic Star Wars familiarity as
possible so I don't know I just wonder
if the sun might be a step too far bar
for the I'm guessing 65 of Ahsoka
viewers who didn't watch any of rebels
or Clone Wars It's Autumn now and if
you've noticed that when you see leaves
falling out of your trees you start
thinking about your thinning hair you
should check out keeps keeps is an
online subscription service that makes
it easy and more affordable for men to
treat their male pattern baldness right
from home keeps offers both of the FDA
approved hair loss treatment options as
well as a two-in-one gel that combines
both treatments the treatments offered
by keeps are 90 effective at treating
hair loss and can increase hair growth
by up to 35 to get started all you have
to do is complete an online consultation
that will get you matched with a
treatment plan tailored to address your
hair loss concerns once you've done that
choose a plan that works for your
schedule treatment plans are affordable
typically half the cost of traditional
Pharmacy prices with 3 6 and 12 month
delivery options it's super easy to
adjust or pause or cancel your plan if
you need to keeps has helped nearly 1
million men keep their hair which is
probably why Keith says over 4 500 5
Star reviews hair loss stops with keeps
for a special offered to get started go
to keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description that's keps.com
new rockstars really let's just clear
update Bologna's intention about the
world Between Worlds he told cinnamon
blend in 2018 that he does not see it as
time travel and really you know what I
think it's just better to play the clip
from the rebel season 4 Blu-ray where
filoni explained it the world Between
Worlds then you know it's not about time
travel it's really not about time travel
at all it's just about a place where
everything comes together
and you hear
different things echoing throughout time
because it's all fluid in that moment in
that place it's not
this material thing that's linear
everything is occurring all the time
and Ezra is more in tune with the things
that are directly related to him like
when he was on malachor install Ahsoka
like when he saw Cain and die
these things reverberate to him and he
understands them more the other voices
he doesn't even understand he doesn't
know those people they're just like the
wind moving and he recognizes some like
Obi-Wan and Yoda but he doesn't
understand the context of anything
that's going on
I don't know how real it actually is I
don't want to Define that for people
anyway but it's not this place of
gateways and doorways that you just go
in and out of now Ezra can pull Ahsoka
into that world remember she's smart
enough to know that she can't leave that
world through his door she'll be
destroying the Natural Balance in order
of things she has to go back from where
she came
it's the same with Kanan when you
understand that if he pulls him out of
that world he he's got to put him back
in a world where everybody's dead and
then you know that wait Ezra couldn't
even been in that world then and so
everything will break and will cause
chaos and will cause destruction so it's
not this
system of doorways like you're on an
elevator getting off on different floors
in different times it's more like what
the wolf tells us or it's more about
knowledge
knowledge that you can use for your
benefits of good or knowledge that will
lead to destruction that's what it's
about but it's not my intention that it
be this
ability to walk through into somebody
else's world
we have to keep being dedicated to being
original and creative and sometimes we
take chances and sometimes we do weird
things like create bendu or you know
mysterious wolves and but I think as
long as you work off the principles of
the force that George set up
that it doesn't change it
and you don't erode what makes Star Wars
special thank you valony so when it
comes to the world Between Worlds it
really does feel like Dave filoni and
the whole lucasfilm family have been
trying to clarify what the hell it
really is ever since in DragonCon 2018
on a Star Wars animation panel Henry
Gilroy said I always got the sense that
if somebody else had gone into that
world Between Worlds they would have
experienced something completely
different they would have heard
different voices echoing the portals
would have been different so it's about
what you bring into it and what your
experiences are and what your
connections are and in October 2021 Mark
samarik's book Star Wars the secrets of
the Sith came out and Darth Sidious and
that book described it like this this
mystical realm connects all of time and
space creating a conduit between the
living and the dead those who control
This Plane would possess Mastery over
all of existence but gaining access has
proved to be an unexpected challenge so
there you go the world Between Worlds is
a subjective experience unique to the
visitor Insidious believes it's a
conduit between the living and the dead
so we should look at the world Between
Worlds here and the subtle differences
in its design as a reflection of
ahsoka's own subconscious and her
experience so using that definition we
could see Anakin as a forced ghost an
expression of the part of his soul that
died spiritually on Mustafar as Vader
took over which could be why he has the
scar on his face like he did when Ahsoka
said goodbye to him in Clone Wars season
7 before he rushed off to Battle of
Coruscant his lightsaber does look
darker but I really just think it's the
Chrome reflecting his robes however
Force ghosts do not need the world
Between Worlds to appear they can pop up
anywhere Qui-Gon jinn's Force ghost
appeared to Obi-Wan on Tatooine in an
Obi-Wan series and you know what they
didn't really have to D age Liam Neeson
that much they did DH Hayden here and I
think there's a reason for that Anakin
or whatever this is is not physically
standing here in the world Between
Worlds the world Between Worlds is not a
physical Dimension anyway this Anakin is
a vision unique to Ahsoka and I dove
deep into the visuals to prove it really
the more important Rebels Episode to
re-watch more important than the world
Between Worlds episode is really season
2 episode 18 shroud of darkness and why
is that episode so important because
it's more of an Ahsoka episode the world
Between Worlds episode is an Ezra
episode shroud of Darkness opens with
Ahsoka watching nold recording of Anakin
teaching her form 4 lightsaber combat
and later in the episode she goes into
the lothal Jedi Temple and sees a vision
of Anakin and Vader
why did you leave where were you when I
needed you do you know
what I've become
baloney a hundred percent wanted to
evoke this moment in Ahsoka this episode
because the framing of Anakin's reveal
in the world Between Worlds is exactly
the same framing of Anakin's Vision in
the temple over ahsoka's shoulder in
that moment and again Ahsoka this
episode ends with the same Vader theme
music we're as likely to see in episode
5 a shot of Darth Vader as we are
anything else and retroactively many of
those trippy moments in the lothal Jedi
Temple throughout the rebels series were
later realized to be our actual first
glimpses of the world Between Worlds so
you don't need the mortise Gods to
access it sometimes if you're just in or
near ancient structures with spiritual
significance and if you're in the right
state of mind you can just find yourself
drifting into it we should also remember
that ahsoka's hand was burned with night
sister magic when she tried to grab the
spear and later when we saw her Palm it
did look like Smoky Scar Tissue was
still on her Palm now since Ezra
bridger's access to the world Between
Worlds was based on his hands connection
with the daughter's hand on the mural
and then he closed it later by
connecting with the son's hand on that
mural ahsoka's hand being scarred this
way alone could be enough for her entry
to this realm Dave filoni's quote
described it as fluid and stomeric's
text described it as a conduit between
the living and the dead and the biggest
live action is the texture of it it is
aquatic it's blue it's like water and we
smoothly transition from the waves of
citas into these ripples of Stardust and
not just water wind felony also
referenced wind when he described it and
throughout episode 4 even in these
little moments ahsoka's laku move in
response to some mysterious breeze so
Ahsoka was not pulled into the world
Between Worlds by Anakin the way Ezra
pulled her in she has been gradually
drifting into this mental state the
entire episode she makes these Anakin
style power moves like the overhead
lightsaber position like Anakin did
against Dooku and attack of the Clones
move by move she's recalling Anakin's
form four training and Balin explicitly
brought up Anakin during their duel
everyone in the order knew Anakin
Skywalker few would live to see what he
became surely that must leave a mark is
that why you walked away
abandoned him your legacy like your
Masters was one of death and destruction
so when Baylen knocks her off the cliff
she would have fallen into the crashing
surf of course and if you look closely
at the wide shot of the coastline back
in episode 2 there is a bit of an inlet
in the rock wall to the left of where
the Stonehenge formation is kinda looks
like maybe there could be a sea cave
there maybe like the sea cave and Notch
two in the Last Jedi that Rey dove into
to mirror the soul Journey that Luke
went through on Dagobah that inspired
Dave polony to create the world Between
Worlds to begin with so here when Ahsoka
sees Anakin she calls him master and he
says hello Snips this is ahsoka's memory
of Anakin that's why he has to be
younger so when Ahsoka fell she hit the
water not just as a physical body but as
a spirit Warrior grappling with her
unresolved issues with her former master
I reference Gandalf wrestling with the
balrog someone ready to go to some
spiritual transformation and to come out
enlightened her proximity to death in
the spiritual history of these sitos
ruins activated in her a heightened
meditative state that allowed her
Consciousness to drift into the world
Between Worlds where she finds the
memory of Anakin so episode 5 is gonna
be a big one Dave filoni is apparently
screening this on movie screens in
certain locations so it's gonna be
cinematic we can expect other memories
that are important to Ahsoka because
this is about her not about the world
Between Worlds as it's some kind of
objective Cosmic plane we could see once
again her duel with Vader a malachor her
duel with Maul on Mandalore moments with
Rex during Order 66 and Clone Wars so
again this is not about time travel it's
not about some God toying with Ahsoka
It's About snips's Soul working through
an unsettled history with her master let
me know your thoughts on this in the
comments below and you can support our
Channel by grabbing in a Soca inspired
fulcrum shirt available at nerd
riot.shop be sure to subscribe to the
break room for episodes of WikiLeaks or
Ahsoka after show subscribe to all three
channels of the new rock stars Network
follow me at avos fall into rockstars
thanks for watching bye
thank you
[Music]